en el caso de los siete estadounidenses
liberados se trata de cinco ciudadanos
también de nacionalidad venezolana
empresarios de Cisco la filial de
pedevesa en Houston que recordemos
habían sido detenidos en septiembre 2017
cuando fueron llamados a una reunión en
Caracas en la empresa en pdvsa y ahí
Fueron sorprendidos por funcionarios de
los cuerpos de seguridad los arrestaron
y los acusaron de delitos vinculados con
corrupción los otros dos estadounidenses
se trataría de Matthew un veterano de la
marina que fue detenido en septiembre
2020 acusado de supuestamente terrorismo
y cuya familia recordemos en junio del
presente año decidió denunció que un
intento de suicidio en prisión la otra
persona que fue liberada osman Cano un
joven estadounidense de 24 años que fue
acusado a entrar ilegalmente al país por
la frontera Estados Unidos había
desconocido estos delitos que el
gobierno venezolano había anunciado por
parte de del gobierno estadounidense
liberó a dos sobrinos de la pareja
presidencial Efraín campo flores y
Franky Francisco Flores de freitas ellos
fueron detenidos en noviembre de 2015 en
Haití y acusados de Conspiración y
intentar ingresar cocaína a Estados
Unidos fueron llevados a juicio en Nueva
York y ahí condenados a 18 años de
prisión permanecían en una cárcel
estadounidense en Florida la prensa
estadounidense ha calificado esta
decisión como el mayor intercambio bajo
la administración de vaiden una decisión
que se podría decir inesperada por parte
de muchos dado que estos dos sobrinos de
la pareja presidencial estaban acusados
en narcotráfico Daniela ahora en qué
contexto de las relaciones entre
Venezuela y Estados Unidos se da este
intercambio
bueno en el propio comunicado que emitió
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro dijo que
estas liberaciones eran producto de las
conversaciones que iniciaron en marzo de
este año cuando recordemos que una
delegación de alto funcionarios de
Estados Unidos visitó Caracas con total
hermetismo y en el que se conversaron
también de aliviar sanciones económicas
a Venezuela para un eventual intercambio
petrolero también recordemos que en mayo
de este año se levantaron las sanciones
que pesaban sobre otros sobrino de la
pareja presidencial que fue tesorero
nacional Carlos malpica y se relajaron
un poco las sanciones que pesaban sobre
la estatal pdvsa para poder iniciar
conversaciones con Chevron para una
eventuales actividades petroleras
recordemos que todas estas reanudación o
conversaciones que se han renovado entre
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y el
gobierno de John vader se ha manejado
con total secretismo luego hoy que en
enero 2019 públicamente Nicolás Maduro
rompiera relaciones con Estados Unidos
bajo la administración de Donald Trump
por este reconocer a Juan guaidó como
presidente interino